today's question comes from todd in
indiana he said my wife and i on baby
steps four five and six we continue to
do our monthly budget meeting
and each track our spending on a daily
basis being the holiday season is upon
us i want to purchase a christmas gift
for her
that would be a complete surprise this
would be a purchase within our budget
means
and would easily catch her attention if
she saw the track this transaction show
up in every dollar
and to withdraw cash from the bank would
certainly
be eyebrow raising as well well todd
this is a couple things you can do okay
number one it's christmas so i don't
think it's gonna be a huge shock that
you guys
are gonna be getting gifts so you could
just say hey
let's each get a gift and go buy a visa
gift card
so she doesn't know where it was spent
and you buy the gift because it's
christmas and
that's what's happening right
anniversaries birthdays christmas kind
of assume there's going to be a gift
but if you want it to be extra stealth
this is what i did i'll be curious if
you get mad at me
dave for this advice i did this for
winston
i bought him concert tickets for a
birthday once
and i actually had my mom pay for them
and then on the birthday after we went
and went to the concert i paid her back
so he wouldn't see the transaction so
and this was all hidden from me of
course
it was technically borrowing money but i
had the money
i just didn't want it to go through the
bank cause i i i appreciate
todd's question his dilemma so genuinely
the gift-giving dilemma so i would be
okay if you had the money
that's okay and you had family member or
friend that had it it's interesting
[Laughter]
no she didn't but you could you can you
can go we still can't get sharon to quit
calling a debit card a credit card so
she doesn't like that credit card you
don't have a credit card she will say
that we get my credit card out of my
purse like mom it's a debit card you
can't
can't say that you're sharing ramsey
geez
man it's the best she's the best anyways
that's that's why that's what i did
yeah okay so just an option
yeah i think your first option it fits
if you don't have
uh mama's secret santa to bail you out
yes